in this capsule we started
our description of the algorithms of
heuristic research then the
objectives of this part of the short this
will be first to learn to
formulate the resolution of a problem to
using a search in a graph
then we will look specifically
the star algorithm to solve this
kind of problem and that will get us to
talk about the notions of ristic and
to explore the theoretical properties of
the star algorithm and finally we're going
see a description of the algorithm that
will allow you to learn how to
implement and simulate the algorithm to
star we will start by looking in
burst different types of problems
that we will be able to solve with the help of the
heuristic search so a problem
very simple is that of finding a
path between two places in a
city ​​so let's imagine I find myself
in a city with horizontal streets
and vertical and that I'm at
certain places
then I want to go to a
some destinations but using
the heuristic research that we are going to be
able to find out what's the path
the most that between the source
the place where our
destination that's an example
maybe a little played and simplified but
really have an algorithm that is
able to be generalized to networks
much more complex where we have
different cities to different
interconnected road networks between
them and like a little like the problem of
who ultimately solved by the website
google maps be able to find a
route between imposition to a
position b
another application example is going to be
that of planning a robot on
has an example here where we have a robot in
a factory with several pieces and
where we actually want to move different
pieces of
so different package actually between
different pieces to reach
possibly a configuration of all
packages that is different than the one to
which we start our problem at
using a search algorithm
heuristic for example algorithms in
star
what are we going to see if it's going to be able
to deliver ckoi the algorithm what is it
planning to do what is the
series of actions offered by the robot
to make her move the way
the most effective possible
another application of algae from
rustic search
it's still an obligation of robots or
for example we would be given a
observation that would give us sight of
as the crow flies the land in which must
to move a robot and in this case
what we would like to do is if our
beautiful start let's say the position here and
we want him to go here but
is able to determine what is it
the path to follow to meet the
fewer possible obstacles remained
on the easiest terrain to
browse for the robot using
actually this type of system there is rather
complicated different algorithms
behind but among others the routine
problem-solving routines
via the star algorithm are between
others evoked in this type of system there
another example this real-there resolution
puzzle game an example of a very game
simple is the npws hall where we have a
grid so in that 6 3 by 3 with
an element of the grid that is empty and
the other elements that would be
associated with tiles with a number one
up to 8 and the goal of the game is to
start an initial setup
and 2 will be in bus configuration or in
this case also a reality of one up to 8
who would go around our crime is
so again with an algorithm
heuristic search it's going to be
possible to find what is next
actions so following the
current displacements
you have an example if we move
the current 6 down so we move
northward the part of the grid that
is empty
so that's a possible action and
with a heuristic research group
we are finally able to
determine the series of actions to be done
to finally arrive at the solution
desire or the solution of an enigma so
in general when solving
a problem we often follow in a way
very general to roughly solve
Any problem is
start by modeling our
environment where the current situation
the context of net applications then
of care to list all the solutions
paul possible a plate of the others
to evaluate the value or blow the
performance measure of each of these
solutions there then finally to keep
the one that is associated with mermoz or
performance or in this case also who
allows to finally satisfy our
goal of solutions and the problem
that we are facing and that for
several applications the number of
possible solutions and exponential and
so this approach to enumerate all
solutions in an arbitrary order
and just not applicable so
the problem to solve is to comment
what we can go through this list of
solutions there in an efficient and
meanwhile allowing us not to
eventually all of them browse and then
to go through a very small whole
is to arrive at a situation where we are
guarantee that the solution has been found
optimal
is what we will see is that in fact
it's possible to do this kind of
effective journey by formulating our
problem as a research problem
in a grave in our graph each
will only match one and todd of our
environment
now every way in our
graph will correspond to a sequel
actions taken by our agent is in
do each
the links between two will not match
finally to a single action taken by
notable to solve our problem
we will have to find the path that
best meets our measure
of performance
so we see that with algorithms of
heuristic search we're going to be in
able to do this exploration there of
our graph effectively for
solve problems pretty quickly